welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and if you're still
in the dark over well dark then this is
the video for you the third and final
season has just wrapped up and there's a
lot to unpack from it the time you why
me wibbly-wobbly series feels like you
need a PhD in theoretical physics to
understand but we've hopefully created a
breakdown that's gonna be dark for
dummies and should guide you through
this series as simply as possible
now obviously there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you haven't had a
chance to check it out yet then I highly
recommend that you turn off now make
sure you drop a thumbs up and don't
forget to subscribe to the channel if
you enjoy the video without the way
thank you for clicking this and let's
get into our breakdown of dark ok so
dark as a whole has very much been about
ensuing one survival no matter what this
has been shown through several of the
characters who pretty much all had to do
something bad in order to guarantee the
way things happen are always the way
things happen atom is a key character
that signifies this and in order to make
sure that Jonas would go and to become
him he killed Martha just before the
apocalypse at the end of season two in
his eyes this would set things in notion
that will continue the loop in which
Jonas would become him and thus the
status quo would remain however dark
through a cave ball in the final few
moments of season 2 and we were
introduced to an alternate version of
Martha that saved him from the
apocalypse the third entry is very much
about breaking this loop and it
culminates with Claudia convincing Adam
to do so by the actions we've seen a
carry out throughout the show
predominantly the three travelers we
need to be aware of are Jonas Martha and
Claudia as they're pretty much who the
show revolves around now my notes for
this look like the walls of a
psychiatric ward but I'll try and keep
things as simple as possible so I will
be glossing over certain elements in
moments just so we aren't looking at an
eight hour long video initially it seems
like there's two worlds with all the
timelines happening at once which leads
to a straight line in which all
intertwine this is actually proved to be
wrong at the end of the show but we'll
get into it now season 3 opens Amy
after the head-scratching ending of
season 2 and it begins with the burning
of the family tree that's been at the
center of the time-travel show this
signifies the message that all must end
in order to save everyone and it's a
neat way to open the series so we have a
sort of subtext of what must be done
if you thought things couldn't get any
more confusing then prepare to be proven
wrong because the first half of the
third entry feels like trying to put a
jigsaw together blindfolded with your
hands tied behind your back the
alternate version of Martha and Jonah's
journey through to a mirror world which
is exemplified by the title sequence
being reversed in this world everything
is sort of taking a similar course for
the last two seasons we've seen however
at the same time everything has changed
- there's minor details that are very
subtle and we can see examples of this
in the chair outside the cave switching
sites it also appears in other elements
such as the house being reversed and
this world be forms not with world a in
which everything travels on a continuous
loop at the start of the season
Martha abandons Jonas in 2019 B so that
he can learn about breaking the cycle in
world B the apocalypse still happens on
June 27 22 way that's today and we see
that Martha and Jonas pretty much switch
places as the traveler this is the
alternate timeline that Claudia was
referring to as the world without Jonas
also shining reference now on the whole
a lot of the characters in the show
exists because of something known as the
bootstrap paradox in this theoretical
situation a scientist finds a book on
his doorstep this book details all of
the ins and outs of time travel and uses
it to build a time machine
he then travels back in time to leave
himself the book and thus the loop can
continue this is how a lot of the
characters in the show are created and
primarily most of them exist because
someone in the future traveled back to
the Past to set things in motion
thus you remove one elements such as
Mikkel and then Jonas can't be born and
everything changes other notable
differences we see early on and will be
other Ulrich is cheating on Hannah with
Charlotte and Waller doesn't have an arm
instead of an eye and Regina tied men
also died prematurely in world a we
learn that older Jonas traveled back to
the 1880s and
Arthur goes to visit him in order to
supposedly lead him on a different path
she tells all the Jonas who I'll be
referring to as the stranger so things
don't get confusing about younger Jonas
from their world informing her of this
which the former doesn't remember and
thus he believes that things may have
been altered in the loop
however we learned that this was
actually done by Adam he knew his past
self would be too gullible to question
anything this was in exchange for Martha
learning about the origin aka her unborn
child and yet it's a lot of time you why
me wibbly-wobbly stuff but basically at
the core of everything you have all of
the characters trying to break the loop
breaking the loop is something we've had
lip service paid to in earlier seasons
and this is the key to everything it was
said that every time a loop happens
something minor changes so if enough of
these minor changes happen then one
thing could end up being the straw that
breaks the camel's back or rather ties
everything together I'll discuss how
this fulfills in just a bit but the
binding of things is something you need
to bear in mind now it's during this
time that we see the stranger slowly
being persuaded into creating a paradise
through sick mundus the final episode is
called paradise and thus the idea that
the stranger has to become Adam is
planted here actually enjoyed seeing
Sigmund is formed and their ideologies
and also failures they basically believe
that time travel can save everything but
as we know from Rick and Morty trying to
use it just leads the society eating its
own tail and it's a path to damnation
this is reflected in tan house who tried
to resurrect his family because he
believed they would be alive in the
macro bursts due to the theory of
Schrodinger's cat however he ended up
creating divisions from the origin world
which gives us an inkling of how things
have happened for our protagonists now
it's great seeing this play out in
motion I loved watching how Martha sort
of became the atom of her own world
as Eva or as Jonas calls her auntie they
are the chosen ones from both their
worlds and the Adam and Eve picture we
see in this season is split down the
middle because of this now we basically
watch the two mirror one another as they
try and navigate the complex landscapes
of the loops and convince themselves to
break it in order to return things to
how they should be a lot of the season
also fills in the blanks and max2
elements that we've only heard about but
not really being privy to you this
involves Elizabeth and Noah Charlotte
meeting Elizabeth in the future
Hannah going to the past the nuclear
plant being built
Katrina tried to save Ulrich Katrina
getting killed by her own mother
the Mads murder investigation bought us
following Agnes and a lot lot more now
one of the most notable elements to be
aware of is that Martha and Jonas
traveled to 2050 to be it's here that we
learned that Jonas has to let go of
Martha in his world in order to save it
and the reason that the apocalypse has
happened so many times before is because
he's refused to both Adam and Eva
throughout their lives have been
basically laying the groundwork in order
to guarantee that things continue to be
the weather they are because they
believe that it will untie the knot when
ultimately it just binds it tighter now
by the end we actually learn that there
are three worlds and that a and B are
the ones that should have never existed
the origin world is actually the
paradise and combination of these two
worlds and it's the way that things
should be dark has primarily moved in
motions of three with a symbol of the
triquetra being something that ties
everything together just as we primarily
got timeline jumps of 33 years we also
have three worlds and so on and so forth
in numerology 3 is a number that means
divinity and this is referenced in the
Trinity of the Father the Son and the
Holy Spirit and Christianity in
Christianity the number 333 is in fact
seen as an opposite to 666 and if you
see it it means you have been visited by
guardian angels that will look after you
éva also tells Jonas that humans lived
three lives and the idea of three is
laced throughout the season now though
the worlds in dark are shaped by duality
such as black and white light and dark
it is far more complex and this third
world is sort of the best of both worlds
if you will that sort of brings what
should have been together thus
everything isn't about time it's more
about realities and making the best one
possible now at a crazy moment in the
season an alternate version of Martha
shows up and kills Jonas hammering home
this idea of there being other options
but what we've been told and this of
course mirrors how Martha was
sure at the end of season two these
switch points alternate certain passages
in action but they always eventually end
up coming back as part of the same path
with the realities overlapping and
causing one another however it is
possible to break them though everything
is put on this predetermined path it
doesn't mean that you have to travel it
this kind of sets up everything for the
finale and we watch as Claudia visits
Adam who shot that she's alive she
reveals that though he's been trying to
untie the knot through killing Martha
and therefore the origin that he's
actually been ensuring that this
causality loop continues she tells him
that he must enforce the way that things
are in the past and make sure that it
all happens exactly the same up until
this one moment that we see happening on
the screen it turns out that claudia has
actually been trying to save Regina this
entire time by erasing all worlds in
which she dies she's kept everyone in
the dark lying to both Adam and Eva
throughout their lives
so things inevitably lead to this
conversation this ties to the theme of
motherly instinct and just in how
claudia has been trying to save a child
eva has been trying to save her
whoo-hee learn is the new man that's
been introduced in the series as well as
his younger and older self claudia says
that they have to prevent the invention
of time travel by tan house which will
mean both worlds will no longer exist
the Gateway to this opens when the time
machine first turns on as a creative
moment in which time stands still and
thus they can break the chain as the
chain does not exist Claudia says she's
already used a moment to change things
in the past and Adam possesses the
ability to do so too however in order
for this to happen things must always
happen the way that they have up until a
certain point which is why Martha killed
Jonas in the scene from failure now
things slightly altered Adam is able to
visit Jonas at the moment of the
apocalypse and together they travel to
we'll be here he tells him that
everything that has happened in world a
and B has been caused because of their
stubbornness but he's finally ready to
change things Adam sends Jonas to stop
Martha from coming into contact with
Magnus and Francisca and thus she will
not become Eva and he will not become
Adam he manages to pull it off and
together they travel with one another in
order to bring tan houses family back
study never goes on to build a time
machine elsewhere Adam burns
picture of adamandeva signifying the end
of their loops jonas tells martha that
they must sacrifice their lives to make
sure that all the sorrow they eventually
go into cause never happens
they are the glitch in the matrix that
lead to their worlds becoming hell on
earth and in order to get the paradise
they wish for they need to make sure
they don't travel down the routes we've
seen across the series Adam visits Eva
as he has always done but where he would
normally kill her he's removed the
bullets in the gun and shows that things
can change it's actually a really
touching moment between the two as he
tells them that everything they've done
will be forgotten as both will be wiped
out they actually share a hug and yeah
it's amazing seeing things change their
love and hate is what caused so much
pain and they're finally at peace after
realizing they can't escape the
labyrinth that they've created for
themselves in the tunnel Martha and
Jonas reached the doorway in the cave
and went on house switches on the
machine they're transported to Nabisco
in which they can see each other's
realities this is the moment in which
everything is fractured and thus they
use it to travel to the origin world
here we witness Marek tan houses son who
has a blazing rail with his father
before driving away into a storm with
Sonya in their child
Jonas and Martha materialize and stop
him from travelling to the bridge which
is where the family ended up being in an
accident that cost them their lives they
convinced him to stop through showing
that they know him and thus save his
life so tan aus never needs to create
the time machine a nurse that the
fractures will never exist Marek returns
to his father and says that he believes
the pair were angels and this ties back
to the number 333 that we mentioned
earlier
now with the world's no longer being
created neither Jonas or Martha can
exist as how they were and they slowly
started to disappear with Jonas staying
you and I are perfect for each other
never believe anything else they hold
hands as they disintegrate which mirrors
the other travelers vanishing to finally
they have broken the loop and it's a
bittersweet moment in which we see them
no longer experiencing the hell's that
they've been trapped in every character
had been trying to ensure their survival
all this time in order to carry on the
loop however they realized that they had
to break it in order to make it so that
everyone else had a better life and it's
a really sentimental moment that speaks
the notion of sacrifice their worlds and
lives will have just been a dream and we
cut to the characters namely Hannah and
Regina living in the original world the
paradise in which there was no
apocalypse we see Hannah Willa
Benny Peter and Regina having a dinner
party and Willa's I isn't as bad Hannah
is pregnant and everyone seems a lot
happier Hannah has a certain moment
where she stares at a raincoat and I
believe this deja vu is her remembering
for just a brief moment there other
lives in the mirror worlds she says that
they have free of everything and no
longer tied to the predetermined paths
that have had them existing with one
another on an almost permanent loop for
eternity she says Hannah felt good being
free of it so we do know that the
characters we saw perish did get a happy
ending they stopped the world from
destroying itself and now they all have
a future that won't involve the past and
so on the season ends with the group
asking Hannah if she's thought of any
names and she stares at a yellow
raincoat and says Jonas before the
screen cuts to black now what this means
is that the Jonas we knew will still
live on in some form Erna there as will
most the characters that we've grown to
know and love however at their dark
nightmare versions such as Adam will
just be a dream and the characters will
instead get happy lives instead of the
torture that they've endured for over
several lifetimes things have changed
but they change for the better and all
of the events that would lead to the
murder of children the death of millions
and more have been taken out the future
because of Jonas and Martha's sacrifice
they finally broke the chain so that the
world could continue without the
versions of themselves that we witnessed
the lights going off and on in the house
symbolized that they'd taken us out of
the dark and into the light
hence the season and series as a whole
leaving dark is one of the best sci-fi
shows ever made
so that concludes our breakdown and
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on it and if there's any alternate
theories or things that you feel like
talking about make sure you comment
below and let us know and if you enjoy
this video then please drop a thumbs up
make sure you check out our breakdown a
Man of Steel which is gonna be linked at
the end we go over all the insane
details in it so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more
also shouts beyond gaming for watching
the series with me as it's massively
helped having someone to talk to about
just how insane this is now if you want
to support the channel from as little as
99 cents a month then please click the
join button below
we massively appreciate it and there's a
thank you you get access to content
early we're gonna come chat to us after
the show either follow us that heavy
spoilers or click the disk or link in
the description below with all that out
of the way thank you for sticking until
the end
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you